welcome back to new rockstars the latest
episode of hawkeye has us all
identifying characters by their wrist
alone and we know it's you willie
kingpin wilson to show us already why
are you hiding just come out reveal
yourself this is rogue theory the show
where we pitch the wildest theories for
the nerdy titles that we love my name is
mt and going rogue with me today is our
very own lady jessica of pizzas it's
jessica clemens hello jessica i'm the
dog
pizza dog top pizza dog it's the it's
the highest highest honor honestly
because pizza dog is the greatest a
character ever introduced in marvel
history oh absolutely winky boy that's
my son and someone always willing to
trust a bro when moving it's whitney van
lenningham with hello whitney don't
trust a bro never trust a bro cause a
bro don't trust me
okay
true facts
a philosopher said that i i yeah a
famous philosopher yes confucius i think
so um and someone who i'm sure has some
new costume designs for hawkeye it's
angelica trey trey was popping it's good
to be back and yes i absolutely do i
also practice archery so it's just this
whole series has been eye candy for me
dang we're going to have an actual kate
barton by the end of the series
i'm getting my purple shirt out yo get
it go we got some great i mean new rock
stars got some great shirts at new
rockstarsmerch.com if you want to just
fight crime in those just saying
capitalism we're doing it so part of
what made this episode so fun were the
insane trick arrows we got to see
finally get put into use i mean it's
we've only had hawkeye for like almost a
decade we're finally getting some trick
arrows thank you jesus with the best
moment being the pym tech arrow creating
a giant mama arrow that crashed into the
bridge somehow the bridge is okay but uh
a lot of other people aren't but where
did that arrow pimtech bad boy come from
well that leads us to our first topic of
today is the pymtech the new stark tech
since hey pym must have equipped clint
with that trick era what other avengers
or x avengers is he hooking up with with
all that resizing technology and as we
look ahead to armor wars will pimtec or
loose stark tech be a hotter black
market commodity what do you guys think
man well okay i guess that my the first
thing that i thought when i read this
question was
hank pym would never let his tech get
into the hands of all these nerdy wells
and ruffians hank pym is a very heavily
guarded man and i was like he wouldn't
give his tech out to anyone he was so
hesitant even hooking up ant-man himself
and i think that uh there is a high
possibility that if mr hank pym is
handing out his own tech
could be a scroll because i don't know
if they're real hanging
on okay so i think we might get to see
squirrel pim
coming up because if tech is getting
passed out i don't know that's not
that's not the og's vibe i think that
that might be a scroll thing this is a
that's a very good point because hank
pym has always been like almost like
wakandan levels yeah don't look at my
technology he's his tack he's exactly
who he is hmm
that is
he is kind of acting kind of different
and fishy than usual so i like to be a
squirrel we don't know who's a scroll
babies we just don't know we won't know
until we could be anybody it could be
you watching it's a dog girl it could be
me not pizza dog it's anybody butt pizza
[Music]
you're in debt now
oh my it literally could be a pizza dog
who knows maybe that's why he's winking
he's like a
squirrel little suspicious just saying
um no i i like that one a lot too
because you know just approaching it
like hank
was it scroll scroll hank i like that
one a lot i think that bringing in
scrolls in here you know we need a
little bit more of that in here just
like beyond you know our track suit bros
but like just breaking it down looking
at stark tech and pym tech stark tech is
so straightforward it's like that
military weapon exoskeleton obviously
you can work with things like nanotech
and stuff like that but
here's the thing is it's always getting
hacked it's always getting hacked
you know that's that's the problem with
that exactly with stark tech but if you
look at pym tech it's more covert so i
feel like stark tech you can have these
you know really scary armies and and
soldiers but then with pym tech you have
these covert ninjas that can like
manipulate time so i think that pymtech
is a lot more intimidating and would be
more costly on the black market i think
that it would be more lucrative hey man
and you're not alone because that was
literally a huge thing in the first
ant-man like those making those uh
yellow jacket suits in an army of them
was a huge reason you know why hank pym
hid all of his pin particles in the
first place because he knows humanity be
up we just love making weapons
out of and there's nothing more
scarier than an army of tiny people
and that's like yeah that's like the
scariest thing is that at that point
what's to stop you from using pym tech
to just create an army of tiny little
iron men that could all exactly grow to
giant sizes and crush you and each time
they took a step the earth would shake
and shatter like no thank you yeah
that's the that's so covert
that is that's a lot super
that's so scary could you imagine scary
i don't want to get attacked by a bunch
of little guys no
the rest of that movie um with the toy
soldiers yes
oh my god that's such a
90s movie small that's always terrifying
tiny little toys like with sharp objects
no thank you i don't worry absolutely
not my feet getting stabbed i'd rather
just you stab me regular uh not little
tiny stabs because those hurt oh yeah
regular stab over tiny stab any any day
i think we're agreed upon any day i mean
no stabs ideally
no steps but then the ranking goes no
stabs regular steps if we had to talk
about
rankings yeah
oh well i hope that if we all end up in
uh you know in in you know one of the
one of the the pym creations the big
house together
hopefully we all have our shank ranking
down so we'll know
the shanking the shank ring dude shank
rank
what you got jess um
oh god uh sorry i got so sidetracked
with getting stabbed by cha like
child-sized women
i think okay so
yeah ultimately i feel like when i was
thinking about this there's like two
roads that we can go down i think a
realistic one is that
um during the blip uh clint stole this i
feel like if you have that much time in
the blip you have time to learn and what
we learned from what if um with him and
black widow trying to find just like any
kind of paperwork about like where zemo
was hiding it's like clint is kind of
stupid but when he puts his head at
something and especially if he's
fighting for someone which is like at
the end of the day every episode he
brings up black widow he's like going to
put all of his like oh he's just going
to over exert himself doing stuff so i
think during that blip he learned how to
recreate some of um hank pym's
technology and created it himself or
just stole pieces of what he could find
and piece together this arrow that he's
been harboring until the moment was
needed which i feel like was a wasted
moment i feel like he should have saved
it for something bigger
but but i think that's one of my that
was one of my theories but then my
second one is like also if we're still
thinking about what if we're thinking
about that wasp is going to become a
bigger part of the avengers i love the
marvel zombies episode and what if and
if they say what kevin feige said and
that it's still canon i think we can
trust that wasp would be there to give
some of the technology and some of her
weapons to the people of the avengers
that she trusts and i think clint is one
worth trusting of the avengers because
he's not so tied to tony stark because
stark industries is basically just the
law now because through wand division
they own vision that was their whole
thing was like vision's body is ours so
it's like anything owned by tony stark
now is owned by the law but nothing like
you said hank pym's technology is kind
of covert it's under it's lane low it's
black market so i think
that
wasp could potentially have given him
this weapon to use in a dire
circumstance just because she can trust
him and i and
i think that's one big thing that marvel
movies have made very apparent about
hawkeye it's like he's a good guy
he's he's worth trusting we can trust
him with our life so i think there's
probably that kind of like little back
and forth that we haven't seen yet or he
stole it when he was playing ronin
i do like that idea of him stealing it
because hey if he's gonna go on the run
as a criminal rodent might as well you
gotta get all the tools you can get and
i'm sure like maybe he wasn't even
thinking about being ronin at first he
was like all right i'm gonna make all
these cool arrows first and be arrow guy
and then he sort of became ronin along
the way and then he's like oh yeah i
forgot i had this cool arrow that could
make things grow i bet there's an even
clearer arrow in there too like there's
some secret ones we don't know about yet
that was like the whole tell from that
scene was like look at all the different
arrows he has and i was like
i get it
he has a variety of arrows going back to
the armor wars i i think stark tech and
uh wakanda technology will become one
i'm holding on to the what if canon
stuff and i want to see pepper potts and
i want to see uh shuri creating weapons
together using wakanda technology and
stark technology and these two powerful
women just doing their own thing and
then we can have hank pym being like
i'm still rich and really weird about
who gets my my stuff so
michelle pfeiffer's back so i don't need
anything
[Laughter]
joey doesn't share food of the friend
group
he definitely is um hank doesn't share
tech i love this version of hank pym but
i think we should all remember that he
is just a rich man that's stingy
yeah yeah
at the end of the day old rich white
dude a little bit stingy so it would
have to be stolen it would have to be
yeah and honestly he would have i mean
like ronan would have had prime
opportunity with hank gone during the
blip so we don't know who was taking
over um the company during his absence
as like the head shareholder ronan could
have stolen it from that guy ronan could
have gotten it from hope or scott in the
aftermath lots of different
possibilities well okay speaking of this
pin tech let's talk about the other
avengers because like what other
avengers or ex-avengers do you think
could also have some secret pimp tech
and like how do you think they could be
using it themselves i just thought of a
tiny hulk and i don't
yo oh my god do you know how much i want
a tiny hulk
it would be because it happens in the
comics he goes to the microverse and
there's like a tiny hulk it's the bat i
want a tiny hulk but it happened sorry i
just got really let's get let's get tiny
hulk in here
so okay we have hulk that's still around
who else is around we have jane james
i'm an avenger i think oh well we're
talking about like avengers we're not
talking about soon to be because i think
the boy from uh
sorry i forgot his name and i feel
horrible because as a black person i
shouldn't uh the boy from falcon and
winter soldier could easily potentially
be
a next up-and-comer for like pim
technology i just think he's so picky
about who gets to use it but we're
seeing yeah in 2021 and we know where
disney's headed so it's like
this is a
he like working with paul rudd's
character in an ant-man is already like
okay this is like a convict this is
someone with four this is this is this
working with this man i don't see why he
wouldn't go and work with people from
the falcon winter soldier series also
because it's just like yeah this is a
kid that's down and out but also i can
trust him more than he trusts like
rogers i'm not saying that rogers is not
the trust i'm just saying when you're
captain america the law is gonna be
always right by you so it's like stay
away it's true but yeah i could see him
coming for that more than like elena
elena wouldn't use it um
technology yeah no not really not really
your bag how do you think do you think
spider-man people will have like cc
spider-man tech in no way home that'd be
great oh that would be crazy now i'm
imagining tiny spider-man which is
basically just spider-sized in my head
now
it's just all come full circle
yeah the spider spider he could bite
someone maybe that's how the multiverse
gets started right right
it's andrew garfield who's on the subway
andrew garfield bites toby maguire oh no
that's how they all appear just kidding
that's like a three-way biting sound
yeah now we're all
spiders we're all spiderman but they're
because they're all really little no
we're all spiderman
what if
well technically i guess it'd be funny
if he did use the alternate um version
of spiderman had to use pimp technology
because our spider-man wouldn't let them
use the star technology that he has uh i
think that'd be cute also just to be
like no this is mine this is my dad's
stuff you can't use it you gotta use pin
technology if pim would that's the thing
though pims like okay so this is what i
was talking about before this happened
isn't pim still technically a fugitive
like isn't pim still like running from
the law so could he even show his face
i think that i think they got their name
cleared at the end of ant-man
did they okay because i was like i was
like
even though he said that like you're
good with me i was like they still did a
lot of and now that like life is
back i'm sure a lot of crimes were
committed
you think becoming a giant figure would
save things but instead you ruined half
the city like uh turning that hello
kitty giant pez dispenser also ruined a
lot of foundation that construction
workers have to work on right it's like
a pez dispenser killed a family of five
hank you're going to prison
you murdered so many i was thinking
hello kitty kaiju is pretty cool though
oh my god hello
hello
let's get that going man that's a whole
series on its own no it's so true like
hank and them are probably they should
be like in trouble to some degree even
though they did save the day
they did a lot of crimes in that movie
that's why i think their stuff is gonna
lay low i think their stuff is
definitely gonna lay low it's gonna be
like yeah the walter goggins thing where
like she like slips money slips like
technology like they're everything's
gonna be under the table between hank
pym and anything else yeah well they're
probably just waiting for the next big
bad you know just to like
you know just just over overtake it like
they're doing the comparison game here
right it's like okay how bad are we when
we can get like the next i don't know
super bad guy in here so they're just
waiting for that next one then they
could pop out yeah okay the pim tags
that i want them to pop out as soon as
possible
is definitely the ant-man catapult
i would uh i would really like them to
be able to shoot
all of their new tiny army that they
have outfitted with pym tech just
can't get back just a regular slingshot
yeah
she's like here you go yeah
or you can like troll isn't it the
trojan horse can you like trojan is that
what it's called the trojan horses and
just put them in a toy
yeah
wait what is it called is it the trojan
horse yeah it's called the georgia oh my
god
i just didn't know where you're talking
about that's hilarious yeah so like put
them all in like you know um like a mint
box or like a a hello kitty pez
dispenser or a toy or something and yeah
you could do like a trojan horse thing
with them that's pretty wild i would
love that okay these are all great ideas
so for that everyone gets one million
points each it's a tied up game these
are all i really like the the the scroll
possibility and all these possibilities
amazing you guys are have brilliant
minds but that is it for this question
but up next we have some theories on the
color hierarchy of the tracksuit mafia
but first there is a brand new latest
obsession shirt inspired by hawkeye
available at newrockstarsmerch.com
they have a really cool design inspired
by the title sequence of the show and
you can even channel your inner clint or
kate or kate by getting it in purple or
kate and find those shirts and all those
great merch options at
newrockstarsmerge.com but hey using the
internet without expressvpn is like
having a first aid kit but not keeping
it stocked up what are you doing some
money could get hurt most of the time
you'll probably be fine but then you'll
cut your hand trying to i don't know put
an avocado and then you'll really need
that band-aid i'm not talking from
personal experience i know how to paint
an avocado without hurting myself but
i'll know i'll never eat an avocado
again every time you connect to an
unencrypted network like cafes hotels
airports any hacker on the same network
can gain access to your personal data
and it doesn't take much technical
knowledge to hack someone like a smart
12 year old could do it like my older
brother when he was 12 could literally
do this like he was very smart boy
expressvpn creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet which means hackers cannot
steal your sensitive data and take a
hacker with a supercomputer over a
billion human years to get past
expressvpn's encryption they just got it
like that if you got the time you can
try but don't do it it works on all
devices phones laptops tablets and more
so you can stay secure on the go because
we're always on the go and we really
like how easy expressvpn is to use and
all you have to do is fire up the app
and click on one button to get protected
one button protection amazing and it's
top-notch security without having to
actively think about it so secure your
online data today by visiting
expressvpn.com
rogue that is e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash rogue and you can get an
extra three months free
expressvpn.com
rogue and hey if you dread looking at
your credit card statements you're not
alone the weight of debt can be
crippling but upstart can help you on
your path to financial freedom upstart
is the fast and easy way to pay off your
debt with a personal loan all online so
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over a million
people have used upsart to get one fixed
monthly payment with a clear payoff date
and rather than looking at your credit
score alone upstart considers other
factors like your income current
employment and credit history to find
you a smarter rate for your loan and you
can check your rate without impacting
your credit score in minutes minutes for
loans between one thousand and fifty
thousand dollars and you can receive
funds as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan which is dope so
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com rogue that is upstart.com
and don't forget to use our url to let
them know that we sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application
upstart.com
rogue guys there's nothing sexier than
confidence and blue chew can help give
you confidence where it counts chew is a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis but in chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and you can take
them any time day or night so you can
plan ahead or be ready whenever the
opportunity arises the process is simple
sign up at bluetooth.com consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days and the
best part it's all done online so no
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line at
the pharmacy blue chews tablets are made
in the usa and prepared and shipped
direct to your door in a discrete
package so if you could benefit for some
extra confidence when it's time to
perform blue chew can help and we've got
a special deal for our audience try
bluetooth free when use our promo code
rogue at checkout just pay five dollars
shipping that's bluechew.com promo code
rogue to receive your first month free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluechu for sponsoring the show
all right let us get on to the next
topic of the show because
it's time to talk about the best part of
hawkeye which is the tracksuit mafia i
mean the second best part after lucky
the pizza dog yeah yes obviously yes
because during echo's flashback we do
see ronin attacking some green and blue
track suits
and this makes us wonder is there a
difference between the colors of track
suits because you know we got some red
we got some green in there we got some
blue is there like a squid game system
going on here is this like star trek and
the colors denote your speciality like
am i reading into this too much or do
the colors actually mean something well
at first i was thinking maybe the the
suits were regional you know like the
different areas were different colors
but then
yeah exactly and then the show
well because we have so many of the red
track suits in the shells like okay it
does kind of remind me of the red shirt
so i'm glad you brought up star trek and
how in the original series red shirts
were known to be the disposable guys
right
um as i'm wearing my red shirt today i
better watch my back but um yeah no
that's that's a that's a good question
i feel like here's the thing
i don't know if it's about the color but
it seems like the layers like how many
layers they have stop
the no
importance
no because here's the thing when they
have the tracksuit you know it's fine
that's like the bottom of the rung here
but then you add on the black jacket and
i feel like that's that's the next level
up you know then maybe in the next
episode we're gonna see a guy with two
jackets on maybe a guy with a turtleneck
underneath it's gonna start to i hope
the reason why mcu kingpin is big is
because he just has a bunch of jackets
has a bunch of different letters that's
what i'm saying it's it's a it's a man a
normal sized man in a in a 50 coats
that series sideways stories from
wayside school where it turned out that
one of you are activating a lost memory
in the back of my mind they find out
that one of their fellow students is
actually a dead rat wrapped in a series
of like 100 trench coats and that was
one of the most memorable story lines of
my childhood so
wow it's like it's like that harry
potter twist but a lot weirder yeah and
that's what these tracksuit people are
they're all just a bunch of dead rats
inside wow you know what i'm i believe
it because we don't know what happened
to that endgame rat maybe he he just
went into a life of crime where did he
go put on a track suit that's where
life of cheese and crying
for the most part and then
for the most part yeah please donate
when i was watching it i was also like i
was like why is the one speaking that
can speak in sign language the only one
allowed to wear an extra jacket
but then i was also like it's just cold
in new york and he's probably just not
used to it but um
i i agree
with
the regional thing kind of so i suspect
that she obviously works under a
different person she's he says like uh
when they're talking he's like uncle
doesn't i'm afraid what's gonna happen
when uncle finds out i like your dad
always put the crew first i think it's a
family business and her she's in charge
of this group of people and hers are the
red
jumpsuit almost a red jumpsuit apparatus
the the
captain
that's their band they go on to make
that is
so she's blink 182 and then the other
one
red track suit apparatus it's getting
wild out here there's yellow
yellow card shirts
yellow jackets
oh good and i am on yellow car but
i think i think hers is just red i think
her is just red i don't think it's gonna
be anything so crazy that it's like
uh
they're from spain so they wear red i
think
but i do think it was good to notice
that in that flashback it was like these
are people maybe either working on
because the dad feels like he was higher
than obviously his daughter was so it's
like his people are wearing these suits
he's wearing this suit he's working for
this person but it's like girl we'll
give you a small group of people they
all have to wear red jumpsuits because i
was
they're all wearing red jumpsuits but
also in all different categories like
one is really close
um sign language to her working with her
and then the other one in red is buying
tickets for imagine dragons so i don't
think
it's like a status thing because i'm
like they're both wearing the same
outfit but one's being weird and one's
genuinely helping um so i think it has
to be like her group wears red not a
rogue theory not as crazy uh maybe she
is the pizza rat who knows i mean
i think that it's totally possible for
uh
for for the
the imagine dragons guy to be a very
serious high up important man i have you
met like ceos and they're weird
they'll come up to you and be like my
girlfriend dumped me for imagine dragons
i don't know what to do like maybe he's
weird because he's so high up that he's
like i can talk like whatever now
um have you ever met an imagine dragons
fan oh they're they're dude
important and ferocious you're looking
at me yeah you're looking you're i'm
terrified
[Laughter]
yeah i'm the biggest imagined dragon
stan um i can't stop imagining dragons
honestly it's uh oh goodness um my
favorite dragons
dragon tails um dragon land dragon land
uh pbs great show can't stop thinking
about it don't know what i'm saying am i
having a stroke problem
is your arm okay what does it feel like
pins and needles anywhere
do we know if in any of the comic books
because from what i read um with the
newer echo i was trying to look into the
tracksuit team and i was like they're
just a bunch of dudes just a bunch of
dudes and tank tops
yeah
so i was it's kind of hard to read too
much into it i couldn't find too much
about it to be fair i did only read like
the most recent stuff i did not look too
deep into it that's essentially what the
tracksuit mafia is there's some vaguely
european guys that say bro all the time
committing crimes i mean honestly it
could be as simple as one of them was
like hey
i don't want to have to wear a suit and
tie to the goddamn office i want to be
comfy i want to be able to hit the gym
immediately afterwards with my guys what
can you do for me uniform wise here and
then they all just adopted drag suits
casual friday never ended and casual
friday never ended for the tracksuit
yeah you are correct
they came in in the sweatpants yeah and
then tracksuit tuesday happened and
they're like you know what let's just
stick with this
yeah you know like
like in mean girls when regina george is
like we can't wear we can only wear
sweatpants once a week it's like not not
if you're in the tracksuit mafia dude
not here maybe if you're in high school
but not if you're at the tracksuit mafia
it's comfort so they can they can do
their best you know on the job before
beauty so that they can be their best
selves every day
they all got shot with an arrow
two of them got stabbed in the foot out
of a ball pin
yeah
that was cool
in there yeah they might need some
kevlar i think kevlar blocks arrows
right chainmail they need some chains
i feel like diving out of a ball pit and
impaling
enemies was like my fondest dream at
chuck e cheese as a three-year-old
that is something i absolutely wanted my
entire life and it was realized for me
last night in in hawkeye
[Laughter]
well again you guys have all had amazing
answers but hold on i have a random
thing that just popped into my mind
right now so the red green and blue
suits like what if this is kingpin like
we're assuming that kingpin is in this i
mean let's be real come on he's
definitely in this you gotta be yeah
he's a little black but what if like
he's in the beginning
that's what my friend my friend
literally was like did anybody see
kingpin and i was like it better not be
that black kid and he was like exactly
[Laughter]
but no um since we do have all these
different suits like is there a
possibility that kingpin goes around and
absorbs different gangs and is like all
right rather than you guys you know
wearing your old colors you wear this
red suit because you're this gang so
like i just know which gang you are
because i'm just absorbing a bunch you
know so he's just like it's really
respectful of their favorite colors
and he lets them
i like that that's really sweet he's
like i know you guys all i already
really like green i'm not gonna make you
change you guys can still wear green
it's okay i know you love it
exactly wilson's a nice man that's a
really sweet thing of wilson fisk to do
that would make me feel good if i was
joining his team and he was like you can
still keep your hair purple i'd be like
[Laughter]
i have yours for life i tried a purple
track suit for sure i'd be in purple
track suit team dude i'd be purple
tracksuit mafia all day let's start it
and jealous oh let's start it let's do
it purple track you're gay
do it wrong
big head kang gang purple tracksuit
oh man i'm a triple agent um
these are all fantastic answers so again
i'm gonna give everybody one million
points each which means that it's all
down to the rogue question
all right gang it was announced this
week that there will be at least three
more spider-man films set within mcu
continuity by amy pascal herself so
because of this quote in a news from amy
pascal pitch me your rogues theories on
what the overarching plot for this new
spidey trilogy will be what do you guys
think is gonna happen in this new three
films from sony and marvel well damn
dude i mean if they keep uh
they're just gonna have tom holland
progressively get older and older so
eventually it's not gonna be like no way
home or homecoming it's gonna be like
spiderman retirement home
and like that's what
or like you know spider-man home for
clothes yeah spider-man
mortgage too high on his home
spider-man annual home loan rates
unreasonable i'm thinking i mean
can we have miles morales in here i want
him i think so i mean we already teased
aaron davis okay i didn't know what the
like in this universe okay yeah i was
like i was still trying to feel it out
right with like all the rules and
everything overlapping but
i
i would definitely think that they're
going to
i i would personally love to see them
start to bring in some new blood and
maybe some miles morales type content
because i freaking love miles morales i
love peter parker but i love miles too
and i think it's time
to maybe pass the torch for a bit you
know i hard agree with you okay that's a
good one i like that all right you got
jessie he's going to die
um and he has to die if he doesn't die
i will die and i bet a lot of you are
worried
[Laughter]
i think he's gonna have the same
execution that sounds horrible but i
think he's gonna have the same farewell
goodbye as uh tony stark
um that makes sense let's be honest uh
tony stark i i think
this might be for me more me than anyone
else uh to me he was like matriarch of
the avengers
like it was like we do anything tony
says um
tony does this even mama tony mama tony
mama tony um my favorite pizza he's
definitely a father figure for peter
and he was also a father figure for
peter so i think like for the mcu he was
definitely the matriarch and
i think that torch has been handed to
peter even though he's like a kid and
he's cartoony it's like we still see
that glow and that hope and sheer
like
joy we get in his eye that makes
everybody else feel the same way so i
think he's undeniably like a fan
favorite
kill him
kill him eventually
he's going to literally be redeeming
everything toward the end where we might
see miles we might see like the gwen
that is a p the spider gwen like we
might see all these other ones and
they're like saying goodbye to our tom
hall and peter parker i'm also assuming
that these three movies are going to be
so far out it's going to be like
oh yeah they're going to be before we
see the last one they're going to be so
far out we're going to see old man tommy
like the old man logan
but it's tom holland spider-man like
that's how far down i'm picturing it
by that time he's gonna be like
robert downey jr and be like yo i've had
my phil
like i am ready to have a great way to
go out and it will be his it'll be his
way and we'll get a new miles morales um
this is how it works uh reincarnation
all right
this is how it does hey you know what
jess i love that so much that i'ma give
you the dub because that is so rogue so
wrong
are you kidding me no one is no one
wants that to happen but it could happen
and like is in like you said miles
morales could easily take up the torch
because that's what happens in the
comics so this makes just our winner for
today's rogue theory everyone collapse
for jess
but yes that is it for this episode of
rogue theory thanks to our guests
jessica clemens angelica trey and
whitney van landing him please follow
them all on twitter these guys are some
of the smartest women that i know
and i love just supporting creative
women so please follow them everywhere
not in real life just online um
uh but of course you can follow me at
mastertainment though i'm not as cool as
these girls but of course you can
support us on our channel on youtube and
also on twitter uh because tyler's doing
some amazing there um but also
check out our amazing merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.com we got some cool
shirts like this i've got superman with
the infinity gauntlet super dope super
super dope if this happened the universe
the multiverse would be over um so yes
go grab yourself a cool shirt and also
if you want to talk more about this
episode of rogue theory or other new
rockstar stuff go find us on discord and
join the conversation there um because
some of the channels we've opened up to
the public so it's really dope and we've
made some channels available to our
non-patrons so you can be a part of the
broader community over at new rockstars
fans on discord but only if you're 18 or
older if you're over 18 and interested
search for new rockstars discord server
and join the conversation but yes again
thank you guys so much for watching we
love you guys so so so much and we'll
see you guys next time goodbye goodbye
live long and suck it
[Music]
you